en las antiguas líneas de frente La vida
ha retomado su curso cinco años después
de la guerra contra el autoproclamado
estado islámico los habitantes de mosul
se han vuelto a apropiar de su ciudad La
mezquita de alurido donde abubacar al
Bagdad proclamó el estado islámico quedo
destruida en 2017 Durante los últimos
combates ahora está en proceso de
restauración bajo el auspicio de la
UNESCO en este momento estamos tratando
de sostener el Domo después volveremos a
instalar las piezas de mármol
construiremos los muros y retiraremos el
marco metálico Para volver a poner el
Domo sobre los nuevos muros y los
Pilares originales
la reutilización de los materiales
originales fue una de las peticiones de
la población para que la historia se
retomara desde el momento en que se
detuvo antes de 2014
además de haber cambiado su identidad el
estado islámico destruyó un lugar
religioso arqueológico testigo de una
civilización el símbolo de esta ciudad
mezquita volverá a hacer lo que fue y
será incluso más las excavaciones
alrededor de la obra revelaron vestigios
olvidados las bases de la mezquita
original que se remontan al siglo 12
todas las decoraciones Los pilares los
fragmentos de coronas que nos hacían
falta y que se consideraban tesoros
perdidos fueron encontrados durante las
excavaciones los objetos rescatados eran
exhibidos aquí
y Los visitantes podrán verlos
bajo estos andamios se encuentra lo que
queda del minarete inclinado de aladba
emblema de mosul durante nueve siglos
para Omar taka que luchó contra el
estado islámico en 2017 es la pieza más
importante por reconstruir aquí estamos
construyendo una muestra de la columna
del minarete para saber cómo conectar
los elementos exteriores con las
escaleras y la estructura interna para
que esté inclinado
estamos muy orgullosos de hacer parte
del equipo que restaura el minarete la
UNESCO recaudó 110 millones de dólares
y más de 3000 obreros fueron capacitados
para restaurar las edificaciones
históricas los trabajos suelen ser
temporales pero aquí un tercio de la
población está desempleada así que
muchos aprovechan la oportunidad su
fallan descubrió una vocación
seguimos trabajando con piedras sobre
todo con el alabastro después formamos
un equipo entero como venimos de la
gobernación de nínive El alabastro y los
elementos arqueológicos son muy
importantes para nosotros en house se
puede explorar ese patrimonio
arqueológico una pareja de arquitectos
lo recreó virtualmente para que los
lugares destruidos no cayeran en el
olvido
los niños de la nueva generación nunca
han visto la mayoría de los edificios
históricos de la ciudad
Entonces cuando vienen aquí pueden
visitarlos y aprender sobre la
civilizaciones antiguas además esta
tecnología nos permite documentar esos
edificios históricos y conservarlos
virtualmente en internet
huyó de hace ocho años es la primera vez
que vuelve a ver el santuario de
navyones en ruinas Desde esa época
es una buena experiencia se puede venir
a ver el patrimonio de mosul
pero a mí me gustaría haber podido
caminar por ahí sentir los olores ver a
las personas
Borrar esos años oscuros tomará tiempo
pero los artistas tratan de contribuir
my lovely Lady fue erigida en 2018 en
esta rotonda donde el grupo estado
islámico organizaba ejecuciones públicas
actualmente su escultor se dedica a
revivir el patrimonio asirio de la
ciudad con esta estatua del Rey en a
cheriff que gobernó aquí 700 años antes
de nuestra era
decidí que nos concentraríamos en esta
civilización y en su arte para educar a
la sociedad y a la población de mosul
porque desafortunadamente solo se puede
acceder a una pequeña parte de su
patrimonio en la ciudad
para los Ibrahim la defensa de la
herencia cultural es un asunto de
familia
su hermano johnés está detrás de nineua
opereta el nombre hace referencia a la
provincia de mosul en árabe su intención
es que este proyecto musical sea
portador de un mensaje unificador hay
kurdos
esta gobernación reúne a todas esas
etnias
impensable bajo el estado islámico que
prohibía cualquier música que no fuera
religiosa hace él empezó a cantar
después de la reconquista de mosulia
Quiero enviar un mensaje
existe el talento incluido el femenino
y tenemos una juventud muy talentosa
[Música]
pero la reconstrucción aún no ha
empezado en todas las zonas el barrio de
almayán parece detenido en el tiempo
desde que acabaron los combates sus
habitantes evacuados en esa época ahora
se impacientan
desde hace seis años vivo en la otra
orilla y tengo que pagar 300.000 dinares
de alquiler no han hecho nada la
municipalidad asegura que los planos
están listos
el barrio Debería ser reconstruido de
manera idéntica por un valor estimado de
40 millones de dólares